we've looked at independence for two
events what about when we have a bunch
of events well in that case we want to
look at the idea of mutual independence
so let's check that out I'll say that if
I have n different events I'll say that
they're mutually independent intuitively
if the probability that one of them
occurs is unchanged by which other ones
happen to have occurred so expressed in
unconditional probability which is the
way to make it precise what we're really
saying is that events a1 through a and a
mutually independent when the
probability of AI is equal to the
probability of AI given the intersection
of any of the other A's of as long as I
is not one of them so take a 1 a 2 or a
1 a 2 a 3 and so on and and a 5 is going
to be independent of all of those other
intersections if we shift over to the
other definition of independence that we
used for two sets in terms of products
you could say that n sets are mutually
independent when the product of the
probability of the intersection of any
bunch of them is equal to the product of
the individual probabilities of the
events in the intersection let's look at
an example of mutual independence maybe
the simplest one is one of independent
coin flips which by definition are
independent so the idea is that I will
flip a coin a bunch of times and I will
let H I be the event that the if-- time
I flip I get a heads so if you think
about what's going on what happens on
the fifth flip has nothing to do with
what happens on the first fourth or
seventh flip there's no causal
relationship between the flips of before
or after flip five flip five is an
isolated event by itself and the fact
that there were a bunch of heads before
or there will be a bunch of heads
afterward doesn't have any impact on
probability that the fifth flip comes up
with a head at least that's what we
believe and that's the way that we would
model them so what that means for
example is that the probability of a
head on the fifth toss is equal to the
probability of a head on the fifth toss
given that the first toss was a head and
the second and the fourth toss was a
head and the seventh Taurus was not a
head this is the complement of h7 so
that would just be an example of one of
the many different conditional equality
equation that hold when you have mutual
independence let's look at an example
suppose that I flip a fair coin twice
then the previous definition didn't
require fairness at all in the coin
flipping but now I'm gonna need it so
that means that heads and tails are
equally likely
I suppose I flipped the coin twice well
let h1 betta as before the probability
the event that a head comes up on the
first flip in h2 the event that a head
comes up on the second flip and let o be
the event that there were an odd number
of heads in the two flips now I claim
that o is independent of whether or not
there's a head on the first flip that
may seem a little weird because O
depends on both the first flip and the
second flip it's whether or not they're
an odd number of heads there but
nevertheless I claim that whether or not
they're an odd number of heads is
independent of whether or not the first
toss was a head let's just check it
using the official definition first of
all o is the event
h.t.t.h if I write out a HS and TS a
pair of them for what the results of
this at first and second flips were I
know you get an odd number of heads
exactly when there's a first a head and
then a tail or first a tail and then a
head which means that the probability of
all is exactly 1/2 because the other two
outcomes are true TT + HH which is when
you have an even number of heads now o
intersection h1 is saying that you have
an odd number of heads and the first
toss is a head the only outcome that
fits that description is HT
which means that the pretend the
probability of H T is 1/4 so the
probability of a intersection h1 is 1/4
o into section h1 is just a peculiar way
of saying you got a head and then you
got a tail so that means that the
probability of O intersection h1 is 1/4
and of course that's equal to the
probability of all which we decided was
1/2 and the probability of h1 which of
course is 1/2 all because we said the
coin was fair
so I've verified the condition for the
independence of O and h1 and therefore
I'm done but the weird thing to notice
now is that if you look at o h1 and h2
the three of them they are not mutually
independent because in fact if you know
any two of them you can figure out what
the third one was but just explicitly in
terms of conditional probabilities the
probability of there being an odd number
of heads given that they were the first
toss was a head and the second toss one
was a head is 0 because once you know h1
and h2 oh you know exactly how many
heads there were there were two and
that's not odd so the probability of odd
given h1 intersection h2 a 0 which is
not equal to the probability of odd by
itself which was 1/2 so they're the
three of them are not independent
they're not mutually independent even
though any two of them are because oh
and h1 are and obviously O&H two are by
symmetry and h1 and h2 are coin tosses
and they're independent so that leads us
to the general idea of K way
independence and an example would be if
you flip a fair coin k times let Hib
whether or not there's a head on the I
flip and you let o again be whether or
not they're an odd number of heads and
by the same argument you can verify that
any set of K of these events are
mutually independent but if you give me
all k plus 1 then they are not
independent in fact any K of them will
determine the k plus first one but any k
of them among themselves will be
mutually independent so that's why this
notion of how
independent a set of a bunch of sets art
comes up and this is how to count it
so in general events a1 through an
arbitrary set of events or k way
independent if any k of them are
mutually independent pairwise then is
just the case of two-way independence
and what we saw was the example that
with k point flips the events odd and
the outcomes of head or not on h1
through a che RK away independent but
not k plus one way independent by the
way now that we understand what k way
independence is mutual independence of n
sets is simply n way independence but I
just wanted to close with the remark
that checking that n events are mutually
independent means that you actually have
to check all the intersections equaling
the products of the individual events in
the intersections so that there are two
to the N possible collections of subsets
of a1 through a N and you have to check
for each of them that the intersection
of those ones that you chose is equal to
the product of their probabilities but
of course you don't need to check the
empty selection and you don't need to
check the singleton set so you just have
to check to the 2 to the N equations
corresponding to all the subsets of size
more than 1 so it's 2 to the N line is n
plus 1 equations to check so in general
there's it's not going to be easy to
verify mutual independence by doing this
kind of a calculation and you usually
arrive at it by really by assumption
most of the time